Ngai Hai Bài tháng bột, bôi trường cúp phòng Trung Quốc đồng quân xây biết
bất kênh sản sản tầm cường của hợp chính được
và làm dấu giác người tắc cúp phòng với nha trong cuộc chào đổi trực tiến
với người đồng cất nha Android B lúc sốt
khi hãng tìm tình hoa sã á, ông đồng quân nhấn mạnh Trung Quốc màu muốn cùng nha từ diện nghiêm tốt
các đồng thuận quan trọng mà lĩnh đạo hành nước đã đặt được
tăng cường của hợp chính được
làm phong cũng đối hàng hợp tác và văn thiện các cơ trế chào đổi dạy bên
bôi trường cúp phòng Trung Quốc cho rằng những bước bí này sẽ góp phần nâng cao năng lực trung trong ở phó với các lửa gó vào thách thức ann anh
cúp chào đổi dễn ra trong bối cảnh Trung Quốc và nha tiếp tục đầy quan hệ lối tắc chính được tăng dễ
đặc biệt trong lĩnh vực cúp phòng và ann anh
rửa lúc môi trường cúp tế và cúp vực đánh giả lạng ngày gặn cúp tạm
hai bên thuật ra qua dùi chỉ tiếp súc thường xuyên ở nhau cấp
báo gồm lối thoại quân xử tập trận trung và hợp tắc trong các cơ trế ra phương
biến a chế cúp bối trị tết lỗi dùng cho đổi
sống các cái bối từ bắt kinh cho thấy
hai nước tiếp tục có hợp tắc khúc phòng là một chủ cột quan trọng trong quan hệ sống thương